in the first Blitz game Kasparov had
white it was a fluctuating struggle very
tense game which finally ended in a draw
probably a fair result
Anand showed in that game that he has a
blast Britt's player who really had
Kasparov worried if you like playing
bliss maybe you know we got onto the
local Geneva chess club and some
information about it outside it's worth
going log there's also descriptions
about some of the games that we've
played in this tournament look at the
opening down interesting back to this
one they're repeating home excuse me
they're repeating the opening from their
first game we're really Kasparov won one
a beautiful girl quite convincingly and
they're playing exactly the same way I
wonder it so far exactly the same way
first 15 moves I could say and then
hasn't that really had time to prepare
anything no maybe he's got a second idea
what's the tryout in this game now
Kasparov having to think again what
should he play in exactly the same way
is this position easier to play for
white or black this is often he's pushed
on with g4 immediately though before he
played 86 first he's changed I guess
what's the first here's a new ruling Oh
and Anand
offering the porn on b2 what happened
tonight xbg 5 no ATK you could have ever
appeared first true
yeah that's another story well okay we
might be possible but uh create a safe
move and attempting to improve his play
in the first game but I'm not so I'm not
totally convinced by this b3 has come
all the same
well it's my move back to b6 then a
three mmm I suppose you just go for a
simple wear something take C to it so
what do you play Queen d2 followed by 95
i d5 actually II six but now are you
going B for chasing around the board yes
it's almost comical how these two nights
I've been hopping all over the place
everything else is do that but okay this
I think is okay for an item a3 looks
very August ease like is getting
critical very quickly nice
dad's d3 what what do you think 93 maybe
then Bishop takes d4 and book take c2
and Queens come to e1 defending the item
b4 advancing those pawns again often you
can take an H Forks you lose the C for
the 1983 model bit silly later on then
we wrote d1 should be threes try to play
are we gonna get the same switch our
palm down to h3 than g3 we almost got
the same instructors in that first game
and somehow I I mean I was very
skeptical about White's positioning that
game no b5 you know they
might be 5 this is quite dangerous
now it takes be 5 is possible with ideas
of if the bishop takes a one Knight to
d6 check XB v this bishop takes me 5 are
both white rooks wrong priests so ok
what do you want bringing this said
economic lines of business where it's
III hold it up in its it is a teller
with it for this lift looks off I don't
I don't like the way an ins maybe you
should say late this this knight on c3
is tremendous and now the rook on d1 is
attacked the pawn on e4 Zatanna cannons
are all kinds drop this is this is a
repeat performance over the first game
look at an ins King is wide open I think
it was a mistake to you should say the
exchange note of the G ported
conversation was open again he'd
obviously didn't have a something beat
happening on the e-file is that on the F
oh it's also funny things are happening
here nice have fun okay Anand has given
up a couple pawns just try to get some
played it looks desperate Queen C 6
there we go we got a same make again is
the same as in the first game Queen e2
defending against the mate this is
pretty ugly on Queenie force I can't
move
it's in the rook they're hitting the
bishop there could be all sorts of
exchanges here just er group to f1 rook
Bishop h6 just wins on the spot because
oh I think and it's completely collapsed
in this game I think he should have
wrote it as a better square because at
least you know ID 5 is the horrible
because part of changing almond 18
dominating the position that's right are
we just a series of exchanges you've got
a very nice ending there's no longer any
problems take it off horns up
technically winning position he's just
exchanging pieces now it's all over your
keeper as well
what's the Queen's xg4 what's Y over
looked
this is incredible the Queen on g4
attacking the rook on c8 now what blacks
queen is attacked on the e3 or I should
have played though in a second Queen the
black Queen moves back Queen check Queen
takes III was just - laughs big
advantage of the club is suddenly what
an elementary blunder from Kasparov he
had a winning position and now how is it
working completely unclear cuz barb
still has chances here it was a rook and
a bishop for the Queen
but and moving the Queen in by default
maybe now efore likes move the idea of
bringing the Brookdale is see and
designs emerge in these pawns good move
the Queen on pinging for stopping he
holds the pawn on e4 good c3 145-pound
two and a half minutes for Kasparov you
better get active rooks III come on
geese is going double the rooks maybe oh
no double Rockies disastrous f7 drops
well this is night c4 Cup I think Casper
was completely lost what an
extraordinary blunder an elementary
oversight 96 - they're not a c5 only I
don't know but the black pieces aren't
really working on harmony are they I
think the most important thing Anand has
got rid of those pawns that were
cramping his King so and king is safe
and I just can't believe that that move
from tomorrow
it's blitz and in blitz all all is fair
okay night c4 there we go d boards all
now aging roads night very nice rate it
takes but Knight d6
what about 96 and then the f7 throws
Knight d6 looks good
there we go check th three the king is
pretty safe on this way you can't get a
rub to the another f7 is caving in and
threatening rook takes f7 f Kasparov
wants to play rook f6 rook h6 yes what
can do what are some way to confuse the
issue more to play Queen to e7 or
something Queen it at least some now
what about rook f/64 played f4 Kasparov
fighting for his life here
is incredible resources again I guess
seven I'm now 95 five across that's
dangerous 95 checking Quincy 622 man
hands now going on the attack
that's right a look at the times one
minute and a few seconds each it's
enough time to get something missing a
half Gaspar a minute given up and he's
giving out now Rick it x6 he gave up his
rook to get some play but he wants to
play rook h6 check check check corn
what's going on this is extraordinary
Kasparov managing to keep chances alive
just when you think of the positions Oh
Burke it's murky but what can you do
with efore followed by rock h6 with some
sort of perpetual that's cutting things
down
good move d4 those depots go across
managed to get rook F for Queen e7 he
just wants to play Queen takes pawn on
e4 and with a material advantage here
Queenie gets Bishop a night that casbah
fighting for his life here how about d3
Queen takes e4 d to rook takes you to a
rook check night if one check that know
it takes Rock On Dude
maybe possibly respond blotting the
clock he's under a minute Hanan only has
47 seconds left 47 is 55 54 when
credible stuff rook h6 check King goes
to G spring can you find a move that
you're a bit late okay 63 night 191
what's this difficult look at for maybe
white straighten rook g4 over the end of
the world
rookie for a wins rookie for Alex oh and
he's reside destroyed
let's just go back to that critical
position in the final game here Kasparov
played Queen takes III blunder and then
V she played Queen it takes G for so the
rook on c8 is attacked by the Queen on
g4 and the route and E one has been
uncovered by the Queen and is now
attacking the Queen III so something had
to give and that's why
Kasparov gave up his queen but a really
terrible mistake instead of that it was
possible just to play Knight takes III
just exchange the pieces the other way
around
and now Anand really must recapture
Queens X III Queen takes Queen rook
takes Queen and simply castles King side
Kasparov is two pawns up here I don't
think it's gonna be terribly difficult
for him to win and next move he'll be
able to play pawn to f5 and just steam
those palms down the board it's just a
completely winning position for black
there was a time when Kasparov was
considered to be invincible
he just went from tournament to
tournament leaving a trail of
destruction behind him times have
changed the cracks begin to show
and his rivals consents
gap between them and the world champion
is now this was the big prize absolutely
delighted
[Music]
you